Hello everybody welcome to this open
house and thank you for joining in I uh
understand that you have expressed an
interest maybe to participate and you
would like to learn about this more and
so that sort why we thought that we will
have an open house which gives us a way
to interact with you people before you
can take a decision whether you would
like to opt for this course which is
somewhat unique in the country and uh
and also is likely to
help in development of skills in a very
Niche sector
um if I can
show you the so we the way we have uh
arranged this open house is that we will
maybe give you a brief overview of the
why do this course and if you do this
course what will happen and where where
all are the opportunities and uh and why
one needs a formal certificate course
because there are many nuances which one
needs to understand even if you are a
user you are as a part of a service
provider in the future you want to take
it up then it's good to be geared up
with this knowledge and then we will
have a brief overview of the objectives
of the program and about the program fee
structure and then
the options which are possible and also
we will have a q a session so that if
some things we have not been able to
cover and you still have some questions
you can
um you can ask can then we would try our
best to answer so I sort of created a
mind map of this certificate program and
diploma which is in the area of Next
Generation omic Technologies and
applications
after kovid I think all of us maybe know
the importance of having our data of
maybe a viral DNA known to extreme
details so that you are able to know
which strain is there and and so many
people were needed to be tested at that
same time and it actually showed the
world that there is a great Merit in
using these next Generation sequencing
platforms for having a very cost
effective and timely manner diagnostic
services so the market size of the Next
Generation sequencing is expected to
rise to around 27 billion US dollars uh
by 2027 that means they are likely to be
a huge number of users and if you have
huge number of users then there has to
be a huge number of trained uh people in
the market who can cater to these number
of users right which is reflected from
the growth in this sector so the at this
point the challenge is that no formal
education actually gears up for uh we're
working on the Next Generation uh
platforms there are needs for
understanding analytic tools and
algorithms which can be used for
for analyzing the data uh there are uh
there is a chilly dearth of knowledge in
understanding what kind of computational
resources one can use and more
importantly when you handle such big
data if you want to find meaning out of
the data how do you give interpretations
so this is this is a major challenge
even for clinicians who would like to
understand uh whether there is a
variation which could be linked let us
say to a particular disease and
sometimes it could be a really a life
and death situation so in this kind of a
context one really needs to have very
good skills uh of uh of these next
Generation
sequencing Technologies and uh there is
a need for trained Manpower that's why
in the sector now who are the which are
the places where this can be useful it
could be diagnostic Labs because
tomorrow's diagnostic Solutions are
going to rely a great deal from
sequencing Technologies because they are
becoming more and more cost effective
and you can get much more value much
more information than when you were to
do one one uh sequencing or one PCR or
even targeted panels for that matter and
the amount which you need to use in
these Technologies then it's very useful
for health and wellness sector as we are
getting into preventive medicine so
there's a lot of focus on uh
understanding risk for certain kinds of
diseases allergy to certain kinds of
food exercise
Etc
diseases per se diagnose social sector
for cancer for many many rare diseases
you want to do diagnosis then sports
medicine that's an upcoming sector where
people want to know the how you can have
a personalized approach to not only with
what sports you can get into but what
kind of training needs Etc there are a
whole lot of things you can get out of
the genome nutrition sector there's an
area called Nutri genomics where people
are mapping their genomic signatures to
Ideal food
in academics it has major use and also
there are if so many users are there
there would be companies who would be
providing the services with these are
very high throughput equipments so
people who are in the service sector for
example who repair these equipments or
give field application Specialists they
are called as where they can get to
train the people who buy the equipments
as well as people who are providing
services so these are all the people uh
or all the areas where you can actually
get into if you were to get skilled in
these training and uh uh and that's why
there's a huge opportunity in uh
upskilling so for example you've done
Masters and you want to get a skill
which will increase your employability
uh for even PhD a post PhD who would
like to move in this area and have not
got the training during their PHD time
any any person who wants to advance
their career for example a pathologist
wants to get into the Next Generation
diagnostic solution as well as
institutions who are wanting to get into
this space and have not got enough
critical mass who is knowledgeable in
this area so these people will be very
useful and then uh in the in the area of
lab technician in the area of if you
have a master's thesis where you are
with the data and you want to analyze
the data or for field application
specialist I as I mentioned and anybody
who wants to do big data analysis or
Implement projects so these are the
spaces in which the generation
sequencing Technologies are coming in
very useful and the way we have
organized the uh the the the whole
courses that we have uh two certificate
courses and these are all uh compliant
with IIT kind of uh structure and IIT
kind of a standard so you have to do 13
credits and 15 credit scores in the both
the certificate so you can actually do
either of the certificate maybe with a
bridge course we would have an option to
provide you that or if you do both the
certificates then you can get a diploma
by which you might actually get a
break-in fee as well as you get to
become an IIT jodhpur alumni so the the
first certificate course gives you a
core knowledge about omics basic design
what kind of Technologies are there how
you analyze the data and then there
could be electives along with the core
which will cater to specific domain area
supposing somebody wants to get into
pathology somebody wants to get into
nutrition sport so they can actually
choose from whatever electives we offer
in that area and the second certificate
again has a core which has an advanced
practical oriented uh uh thing where if
you were to really get onto a workbench
and you want to know how you get the
samples how you process the samples what
are the Technologies how you analyze the
sample as well as there will be an
immersive component where you come to
the lab in IIT jodhpur and do the
practicals yourself and there would be
electives in uh in specific domains and
here you can get to do a project so you
can walk in with a project or we can
give you a project whatever way there is
a freedom here and uh and in future
maybe we are planning for uh uh M Tech
so if you have these certificates
already done and in future if we
actually offer mtech then these
certificates would be valid during that
time uh there are lots of challenges in
the omics it seems like it's a machine
and there is a person at the end who can
give you data but that is not all and
it's very important for you to
understand even if you are giving your
data to a service provider what are the
standards what are the quality assurance
what kind of design you need to study
because omics is like a fishing
Expedition and if you don't know which
which to catch then you will get lost in
it right so here uh the challenges are
the complexity in the data it can be a
varied kind how you protect the data and
if the technology keeps on changing how
you anchor your information onto
changing data sets changing platforms
Etc and then there are many many
challenges in the wet lab experiment in
in terms of preparing samples in terms
of understanding it and also if you are
in a Big Data space how do you manage
such a such a stream data it cannot be
managed just by Excel
sheets so you require certain basic
languages which are now very easy to
pick up and also uh the final part is
the data interpretation so so what we
have is
a reshaping a skill based approach where
we build a skill Workforce which are
proficient in omic Technologies and we
would like to
narrow the uh Gap from training and
expertise because even if a company
wants to hire a person they want well
trained people so that they they don't
lose time and money in training people
and that's what is happening in most of
the places because there's not enough
tree gained Manpower so every company
would want to have the train so as a
result of which we anticipate that a
large number of placement opportunities
are likely to be there for students who
are really performing well because
there's a huge market demand Even in our
country and this put uh provide skill
sets to plan out multi-homic experiments
so uh so I'll hand over the the next set
of slides to my colleague Dr pankaj
yadav and he will take you through the
program